MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you for coming, everyone.
We have a special
guest today on the day
that his new book is released.
So this is a real
treat for us at Google.
Alva Noe is a writer
and philosopher,
specializing in human experience
and the philosophy of mind.
He holds degrees from
Columbia, Oxford, and Harvard,
where he earned his PhD.
He's now a member of
philosophy faculty
at the University of
California, Berkeley,
as well as Berkeley's Institute
for Cognitive and Brain
Sciences and the
Center for New Media.
Outside of academia,
you can find his writing
on NPR's "13.7, Cosmos
and Culture," where
he's written about
topics from PTSD
to Wilmer Flores and
the New York Mets.
He's the author of four
books, "Action in Perception,"
"Out of Our Heads," "Varieties
of Presence," and his latest
work, which is the
aforementioned book released
today, "Strange Tools."
In this subtle and
enthusiastic new book,
he draws on examples from
keeping score at a baseball
game, to Nirvana, to
avant-garde art exhibitions
to lay out a new way of
understanding art-- one that
avoids the reductionist approach
of neuroscience and reframes
art as a crucial
practice of human life.
For more in that
topic and to celebrate
the release of
"Strange Tools," please
give a warm welcome to
our guest, Alva Noe.
[APPLAUSE]
ALVA NOE: Thank you very
much for that warm welcome.
And yes, it's a very
exciting day for me.
I've been working on this
book for a long time.
And I've given dozens of
talks about different aspects
of the book that feed into it.
But I'm never given
a talk on the book,
where the books sort of exists
already independently of me.
And it's an
interesting challenge
to think about,
now, what to pull
from it to share with you as
sort of an invitation to it.
The book is called
"Strange Tools."
It's about art and human nature.
The questions that guide the
book from start to finish
are, what is art, why does
art matter to us as much as it
does, what does art tell us
or what can it tell us about
ourselves.
And I thought I would
begin by reading
two pages from Chapter
9, which is called,
"Why Is Art So Boring?"
Did I hear a chuckle?
"Do you remember
being bored as a kid?
I recall summer days
during vacation that seem,
as I think back on them now,
to have been fantastically,
impossibly long, hot, endless,
open, without organization,
irritating, the buzz
of flies, fighting
with my little brother,
nothing to do, parents remote."
"By and large, there's
no place for this sort
of radical boredom in the life
of an adult. As you get older,
life gets organized around
projects, and plans, and needs,
and goals.
And the result of this
congealing of activity
is that time speeds up.
Or we simply stop paying
attention to the metronome
and are captured
by larger patterns
of meaning and organization."
"Our days are over,
one might almost
say, before they have
begun, for we've already
defined the present
moment in relation
to what is yet to happen, in
relation to the purpose, point,
or plan.
What did you do yesterday?
Oh, I went to work.
And this is all for the good.
It's a necessity."
"We achieve this.
We do not live in the tick-tock
motion of sensations and buzzes
and one thing after another.
It's the mark of
our development,
of our integration, to
use John Dewey's phrase.
Our lives are not made up
of a series of sensations.
They're composed of
experiences, experiences
that demand to be named,
that dinner in Venice,
going shopping, the softball
game last weekend, my visit
here to Google."
And these experiences
integrate over time."
"Grown-ups don't get bored.
Grown-ups can't get bored.
For that distinct,
emotional state,
vaguely painful,
that sense of being
trapped in the unending
and meaningless,
that state is available only in
the absence of structure, plan,
task, obligation.
The preconditions for boredom
are absent in adult life."
"Now, what does this
have to do with art?
My conjecture is everything.
The closest I have come
as an adult to reliving
the florid, boredom
of childhood is when
in the presence of art."
That's another
chuckle opportunity.
"Don't get me wrong, I love art.
I work with art.
I study art.
I was raised in a
family of artists.
Art matters to me.
And yet, it's hard for
me to think of anything
more slit-your-wrists dull
than some performances
or more excruciatingly
sleep-inducing
than encountering,
again, a gallery space
with pictures on the
wall, each of which,
to begin with at
least, is closed, mute,
indistinguishable,
and off-putting."
"It isn't just bad art
that is liable in this way
to induce that feeling
of anxious capture
by an endless and
meaningless present.
I stood in galleries at The Met,
or The Frick, or other museums
that I love, and I found myself
totally cold in the presence
of work that I know and value.
It's as if someone failed
to press the on button.
the work stays off or I do.
And this time spent with
art in the standby mode
can be a torture."
"I propose--" it's one
of the many proposals
that I make in this book--
"that the boringness of art
is a clue to what art is
and why it matters to us.
Any adequate account of
what art is and of its place
in our lives must
address the striking fact
that art has the
power to bore us.
This is a power
it maintains when
everything else in our lives
mitigates against boredom."
"Art affords us the
opportunity to be
bored to tears when almost
nothing else in our life does.
And art's potential to be dull
does not contradict the fact
that art also moves, and
thrills, and transforms,
and excites us.
Indeed, it's the opposite
side of the very same coin."
"Just as there is no
encounter with love
without the live
risk of heartbreak,
so there can be no
confrontation with art
that does not open up the
possibility of getting lulled,
unconscious, and bored to death.
Art is valuable only
in direct proportion
to the degree to which
it can or might bore us.
Why should this be?"
That's Chapter 9.
And by the time
I've gotten there,
I've sort of set the stage
for what an answer to that
would look like.
But for now, I want to kind of
let that just hang out there
with us as a kind of prologue.
When I was in graduate
school, I studied philosophy.
But from the very
start, I was interested
in cognitive science.
And I was especially interested
in the study of vision.
And one day, I found
myself in conversation
with a man, an older
man, an artist,
and he asked me to tell
him about vision science.
What do you do in
vision science?
And I said, well, the question
that we ask in vision science
is, how is it that we manage
to experience this three
dimensional world of solid
objects and surrounding space,
when what we're given
in the retinal image
are really distorted, upside
down, twitching, shifting,
gappy pictures?
How do we get from such
an impoverished stimulus
to such a rich experience?
How do we experience
so much visually
on the basis of so little?
And the artist, a man I
admired and knew very well,
he sort of paused a beat, tried
to absorb what I just said,
and then he just said, Nonsense!
The question is not,
or should not be,
how do we see so much on
the basis of so little.
The interesting question is why
we see so little when there's
so much around us to perceive.
Well, I came away
from that conversation
thinking he just didn't
understand the point.
But years went by,
and I wrote the books
that were mentioned
in the introduction--
"Action in Perception,"
and "Out of Our Heads,"
and "Varieties of Presence."
And the basic idea
of those books--
which I wrote from the context
of my own active collaboration
with scientists; I wrote
those books very much with one
foot outside of
academic philosophy--
the basic idea of
those books was
that we shouldn't think of
perception, or consciousness,
or experience as something
that happens inside us, not
in the brain or anywhere else.
We should think
of experience, we
should think of
consciousness, as something
that we enact or perform.
And while it depends
on what's going on
inside us, and
particularly in our brains,
it can't be reduced to what goes
on inside us or in our brains.
Perception and
consciousness is--
so I argued in these
books, convincingly
or not as the case may be--
consciousness is an activity.
It's a dynamic of involvement
with, an exchange with,
the world around us.
The body the world the brain
the environment other people
make consciousness happen.
Trying to find consciousness in
the brain-- which, of course,
nobody's been able to do--
is looking for consciousness
in the wrong place.
It's like looking for
the value of the money
in the paper it's printed
on, or like looking
for the dance in
the dancer's body.
It's just a confusion,
so I argued.
And it dawned on
me at one point,
as I remembered back
to that conversation
I had had in graduate school,
that I had developed a view-- I
called it the inactive
approach, sometimes
the actionist approach,
sometimes the sensory motor
approach to perception
consciousness-- that
sort of vindicated what
that artist had said to me.
There's really
two different ways
of thinking about experience.
You can think of
something we achieve
and we can fail to achieve.
Or you can think of experience
as something that sort of just
happens, thanks to the way our
nervous system is triggered.
And I was planking down
for this other view.
So in some sense, I realized
looking back on this work
that I'd done,
that I was arguing
that the artist was right.
And that was important to
me for a number of reasons.
But one of them then dawned
on me only even more recently,
which is that it
wasn't just that--
and again, you don't have to
agree with me about this--
but it wasn't just that
I'd come to conclude
that, in some profound sense,
the artist had been right,
but it was important
to me, I realized,
that the artist was right.
That is, I'd gotten this
lesson, I'd gotten this insight,
from an artist and
from a perspective that
had been afforded to him in
some way through his work
through his in engagement
with, through his valuing art.
Now, usually when philosophers,
or cognitive scientists,
or psychologists try
to write about art,
they think of it as a phenomenon
that they're going to explain.
They're going to tell
you why it exists
from an evolutionary
point of view.
Or they're going to show you
how it works neurologically.
But I came away then--
again, thinking back
on this rich
experience that I had,
this conversation--
thinking, no, we
shouldn't think of art as a
phenomenon to be explained,
but rather art as itself
a field of research
or a domain of investigation,
a kind of inquiry
in which explanations
are sought.
We can think of art itself, the
work of dancers and painters,
for example, as
forms of research.
So one of the questions
I came to think
hard about as I approached
writing this book is, well,
what kind of research?
What kind of research is this?
And by the way, long before
I wrote "Strange Tools"--
this sort of sounds
self-congratulatory,
but it's really
part of my journey--
long before I wrote
"Strange Tools,"
long before I even really framed
for myself the idea of writing
this book, artists were
responding positively to these
other books that I'd written,
these books that were really
written for people interested
in the mind and consciousness,
really for cognitive
science broadly construed.
And they were finding
some idea that I
was helping them articulate
what it was that they
were investigating in my work.
Anyway, that's kind of an aside.
I don't really know how
to finish that thought.
But the point is I've come
to this point-- and in a way,
this is perhaps
the most salient,
most prominent thesis in
this book "Strange Tools"--
one of the main themes of
the book is the idea that art
as a research
practice, specifically,
it is a philosophical practice.
I might just as well have said
that philosophy is an aesthetic
or artistic practice.
And one of the things
I do in the book
is I try to explain that,
or unpack that, or give
that meaning, especially
give that meaning
when terms like
philosophy of themselves
is difficult to define and
explain and maybe just as
problematic as notions
like art itself.
And the final position
that I arrive at,
and which I explain in
the body of the book,
and which I'll try to explain to
some degree with you right now
is that, actually, the sort
of official view at the end
is not that art and
philosophy are the same,
but that each of them is a
species of a common genus.
And that common genus I call
reorganizational practice.
And just in a line, the
thing about reorganizational
practices is that they
exhibit us to ourselves
and, in doing so, invariably
give us the resources,
whether we like it or
not, to change ourselves.
Let me make a first pass at
some of those ideas-- a very
informal first pass.
I gave a talk at Google
a number of years ago,
when "Out of Our
Heads" came out.
And I gave a version
of this example
then, too, because it's a rich
example that I come back to
again and again.
Imagine you're at a gallery.
And there, you encounter
paintings, let's say.
And imagine that
they're in a style which
is completely strange to you.
Maybe they're by a painter
you've never heard of or never
seen, or they're
part of a movement
that you're unfamiliar with.
It's a very familiar,
very normal experience
that you kind of walk in.
Maybe you're with a friend.
You're talking.
The pictures don't
grab your attention.
They all kind of look the same.
They certainly
don't fascinate you.
And left to your own devices,
you might very likely just
continue on to the next
room looking for something
more attention-getting.
But I'm interested
in what happens
when you don't do that--
when you don't keep on going,
when you don't
simply just pass by,
but when you stop and take
another look and look again.
Suppose that the
friend you're with
is a huge fan of this artist.
And she calls your attention
to features of the work
that you hadn't noticed-- maybe
patterns in the composition
or in the color
scheme or relationship
between the different pictures.
Or maybe she points
out something
about the order in which
the pictures were made,
or something about the
historical context in which
they were made, or the kind
of work that was going on
at the time they were
made and what this
would have meant to
people who saw it then,
whatever it might be.
Sometimes, if you're lucky,
something remarkable happens.
Whereas, all the
pieces basically
look the same at
first, now they start
to pop out at you
as individuals.
And whereas before, they
seemed flat and uninteresting,
now you start to, as it
were, see depth in them,
or see into them, see structure,
see meaning, and indeed find
them to be fascinating.
Whereas, before they were
dull, now all of a sudden,
they are attention-getting.
So I'm very interested
in that transition.
I mean, I think we have
all had that experience.
If you've ever spent
any time with art,
you've had that experience.
Or with a record
album, I can remember
the first time I listened
to Led Zeppelin's
"Houses of the Holy."
I couldn't understand what
people liked about it.
Just one song sounded
like the next.
I came to love the album.
And I came to
perceive the structure
and subtle differences
between the songs.
So how do we understand
this transformation?
It's a transformation,
which I think of as one
from not seeing to seeing.
Or as Nicole [? Pizzel, ?]
who's here in the audience,
put it to me from seeing
to seeing differently.
You might say, well,
it's a change in you.
After all, the works
haven't changed.
We're not talking about
kinetic art or digital art that
might actually be changing.
I'm just imagining
paintings in the wall.
So the paintings
haven't changed.
If there's a change,
there's a change in you.
But I think it's important
to realize that it's not
merely a change in what
you think or believe,
because whatever the
change is, I would argue.
It's a change that enables you
to see what was there all along
but they couldn't see before.
It's a change that enables you
to bring with what is there
into focus, to
bring it into focus
for your conscious experience.
Now, one way I
could summarize what
I'm trying to do in this
book is to understand
that transformation.
I call it reorganization.
How is it that in that
situation through active
looking, through
thinking, through talking,
and through interrogating the
things before you that we come
to experience them differently?
How is it that we reorganize
ourselves in that way?
Notice that what I
described as such,
doesn't really have anything
special to do with art.
It's a general feature
of our perceptual lives
that through learning
and knowledge and talking
and interaction
we achieve access
to what there is around us
in our perceptual lives.
Think of how you
learn a language,
and then you can read.
You couldn't be offended
by the racist graffiti
if you couldn't read
the language it was in.
Suddenly, you can read it, and
boom, you can be hit by it.
So we can bring the world
into focus through learning.
And it happened really quickly.
So in some sense,
this gallery example
I've given you isn't an
art-specific example.
But there is something
about it which
I think is maybe a clue to what
makes art special or at least
one of art's special gifts.
And that is that a visit
to the gallery of this kind
is one in which you get the
opportunity to catch yourself
in the act of doing just that.
It's not just that you
undergo a transformation,
but you realize that you're
undergoing the transformation
and it's made available to you.
Now for me, that is a
paradigmatically philosophical
kind of moment, where you in
a way stop business as usual
but get to reflect
on what you're doing.
It's one of the
things that philosophy
aims at-- that kind of
self-disclosure or unveiling
of oneself to oneself.
And moreover, in
this example, it
does it in the setting of
the exercise of our abilities
to look and think
and see, that is,
in the setting of
our real lives,
in the setting up
our lived experience.
So the ways in
which we reorganize
and the ways in which
we transform ourselves
have to do with perception
and consciousness.
So if this is
right, then there's
a sense in which what this
encounter with art is affording
us is not just an
episode in consciousness
but a kind of revelation or an
insight into what consciousness
is.
So I take this to be
a very rich example.
And I could spend the
whole talk just talking
about this example.
And I won't, but I'll just
mention as a footnote,
it's interesting to think
about, to compare this
to a platonic or
Socratic dialogue.
The kind of transformation
that happens in this visit
to the gallery for me
is very much like what
happens between Socrates
and his interlocutors
and their dialogues.
But there is one last note
I'll mention before I go on,
more substantively.
And that is, I think this
example also gives us
a hint as to what
goes on when we think
about the boringness of art.
Welcome.
Because what's
striking about-- what
was required to set
the stage for you
to see what you couldn't
see or to see what you saw
but differently,
what was required
was a kind of a disruption,
a moment of not being
able to see it, a
confrontation with stuff
that all looked the same.
And in our natural,
habitual, organized living,
the natural thing to do when
everything looks the same,
is uninteresting,
is to keep on going.
But what the work
ritually-- sort
of the art situation
invited you to do
was to disrupt those habits,
to put the email away,
to stop the
conversation-- rather,
the conversation that's
unrelated to what's
going on around you,
and look to the work.
And so I think, we begin to see
a way in which the work creates
a setting in which boredom
is a stage through which you
have to go to make discovery.
So that's a first pass.
I now want to approach these
issues, these very same issues,
but in a slightly
different manner.
And just in case any of
you are pressed for time,
I'm thinking that I'll probably
go about 20 more minutes.
And then there'll be
time for discussion.
OK, so cut to a new situation.
We're mammals.
And the hallmark of mammals is
that they suckle at the breast.
It turns out that,
of all the mammals,
humans are really
bad at breastfeeding.
So bad are we at
breastfeeding, that it's
been hypothesized that the
function that breastfeeding
plays for us isn't
primarily feeding,
but rather that we
feed that way in order
to accomplish something else.
When I say that
we're about it, I
mean most mammals will draw
milk until they're stated
or until another
sibling makes them stop,
but not the human being.
The human being falls asleep.
The human being hears
a noise and stops.
And as a result of this,
the mother-- and this
goes for breastfeeding
just as well,
it has nothing to do with
the mother-- excuse me,
with bottle feeding
just as well.
It needn't be the mother.
It needn't be a woman who's
engaged in this interaction.
But what happens is that the
breastfeeder or the feeder
needs to have a
negotiation with the infant
in order to help
the feeding happen.
So a typical kind
of scenario is baby
feeds and then falls to sleep.
Mother notices that the
baby has fallen asleep,
and jiggles the baby, and
draws its attention back
to the task at hand. [CLAPS]
And then there's a loud sound,
and the baby turns, and looks at
the sound, and gets distracted.
And the mother
notices that the baby
is no longer feeding
and coaxes the baby back
to the task at hand, and so on.
I'd like you to
notice six features
of this interaction
between infant and feeder
that I've just described.
The first is that in some fairly
straightforward obvious sense
it's primitive, it's
spontaneous, it's biological,
it's natural.
But notice-- and this
is the second feature--
that for all that
it's spontaneous
and primitive and
biological and natural,
it's also incredibly
sophisticated in the suite
of cognitive and
perceptual skills
that are exercised during it--
doing, undergoing looking,
listening, noticing,
responding, communicating.
It's a very subtle
exchange that happens.
It exhibits smarts.
Here's a third feature of
the breastfeeding scenario.
It has a kind of spatial,
temporal dynamics.
It involves rocking and
something like turn taking.
In fact, it's been noticed
that it's sort of remarkable
that the one mammalian species
with full-blown linguistic
powers is also the
one species that
has this kind of problematic
style of breastfeeding,
almost as if to suggest that
the breastfeeding itself is
a kind of practice
run for conversation,
a kind of primitive
form of conversation.
Here's a fourth feature.
Breastfeeding is--
I mean, the mother
is obviously the authority
figure in that exchange.
But this dynamic
I'm talking about
is not one that she
dictates or authors.
It emerges in the dynamic
interaction between them.
So this structure, this temporal
dynamic, this turn taking
is not written-- it evolves,
it happens, it emerges.
Here's a fifth future.
Breastfeeding obviously
has a function.
It's embedded in needs--
probably the needs for feeding,
but maybe other
needs, like the needs
for the release of oxytocin and
the establishment of attachment
relationships.
Maybe that's why we
breastfeed-- so that we
can enter into that kind of
intense, dyadic relationship
that is so important
in our lives.
And the sixth future
that I want to mention
is that breastfeeding
is a place, or a site,
or an occasion, or an
opportunity for feeling,
or for affect, and indeed, if
all goes well, for pleasure.
Now, the reason why I'm
describing breastfeeding
in my lecture on arts
at such great length
is that I actually think
that breastfeeding exhibits
a structure which
turns out to be
very important for understanding
human life more generally.
I'd like to say that
breastfeeding is an organized
activity.
Now, organized activity,
that's English.
That's not technical language.
But I want to use it
in a precise sense
and so in a technical sense
to mean an activity that
exhibits those six features--
that it's primitive and yet
cognitively sophisticated,
that it exhibits
a spatial, temporal dynamics
without being authored,
that it has a function, and that
it can be a source for pleasure
or feeling.
And I want to say that
any other activity that
exhibits those six features
is an organized activity too.
So I'm using the
example of breastfeeding
to introduce a concept--
the concept of an organized
activity.
And what I want to offer you is
the thought that, once you've
got the category of
the organized activity,
organized activities are
very widespread in our lives.
Everywhere you look, you see
organization of this kind--
un-authored modes
of organization
in which we find ourselves, as
it were, by habit caught up.
Take conversation itself.
We think of
conversation in a sort
of classical, Western,
intellectualist, philosophical
way, as two intellects
expressing thoughts
in the garb of language,
using a code to communicate.
But if you actually
watch people talking--
and there's a very
well-established and decades
old literature on this-- if you
actually watch people talking,
something goes on
between them which
is much like breastfeeding.
So when two people
talk together,
their bodily
posture, their tilt,
their attitude in
relation to what's
going around them, their
eye movements, their volume,
their distance in relation
to each other and things
around them, and their word
choice are all modulated.
There's this
incredible coordination
that happens between them.
It happens spontaneously.
It's the very essence
of intelligence
to be able to participate in it.
It's thoughtful.
It has a clear-- it's a
spatial, temporal thing.
It's a dynamic of interaction
between the people
talking, which neither of
them is deciding to do.
It's not by choice.
It's not authored.
Conversation is
clearly functional.
And conversation, when all
goes well, is clearly, at least
potentially, a
source of pleasure.
It's definitely a place
where we have feelings.
Conversation is an
organized activity.
In my first book,
"Action in Perception"--
and I'm not going to
review that book here--
but I'll just say that I argued
that perception is an activity
of exploring the environment,
making use of a certain kind
of sensorimotor skill.
I used the word activity
there without, at the time,
having a clear idea
of how to analyze
what activity might mean.
But I now would like
to say-- and in my book
I try to develop the thought--
that the relevant kind
of activity that perception is,
is an organized activity, one
that needn't involve
other people.
So every time you move, you
produce a sensory event.
You move your eyes, you move
your head, you move your body,
you produce a sensory event.
You approach an object, it
looms in your visual field.
You blink, you modulate your
sensory relationship to it.
We have a kind of dynamic
exchange with things around us,
that I think exhibits the
six features that I just
enumerated, that are definitive
of organized activity.
So the conclusion that I
want to make at this point
is that we are organized.
We are organized
throughout our lives.
By the way, just little
note, a big theme
in the book and the
reason why the book
is called "Strange
Tools" is that I think
a major part of the story, about
how organized activities work
in our lives, is
technology and tools.
Just to be very simple
right now, tools I think
function in the setting
of modes of organization.
So you can look at the thing,
you could talk about technology
by looking at the evolution of
the technologies themselves,
or you can think of them as
evolving modes of organization.
Every tool, every technology
is I think the hub of organized
activities.
It's the focal point.
If you like, it's the
organizing principle.
It's the thing which sets up
and gets the organization going.
So organization of this kind
is very, very widespread
in our lives.
One friend of mine who
read this book early on
said, organized activity
sounds like you're
writing for a business seminar.
Don't talk about
organized activities.
But I think I like the
word organization too,
because organization is linked
to organism and to biology.
We are organisms.
And if there's anything
that distinctively marks off
the difference between the
organic and the inorganic,
is its capacity for, as
Immanuel Kant put it,
self-organization of
something like this kind.
So I want to offer the
thought that A, organization
of this kind, what I'm
calling organized activity,
is ubiquitous in our life.
In some sense, our lives
are nested structures
of organized activities or
structures of nested organized
activities.
I want to suggest that this
has something to do with what
we are as a biological animal.
This has to do with our biology.
And therefore, any account
of organized activity,
which is going to
be adequate, needs--
or rather, any account
of our biology that
is going to be adequate to
account for human nature
needs to have something
to say about this kind
of organization.
And finally, and this
is a more soft point,
but I think we're lost in the
seas of our own organization.
We don't organize ourselves.
We find ourselves organized.
Sort of the image
that-- as I was thinking
about how I was going to present
this to you this morning,
I had his image that popped into
my mind of Gregor Samsa, who
wakes up one day
in the Kafka story
and finds that he's
turned into an insect.
We just find
ourselves organized.
It doesn't necessarily
terrify us.
But we just find
ourselves organized.
So it's sort of an
existential issue for us
to get a better
understanding of the ways we
find ourselves organized.
Moving on, here's
another example
of an organized activity.
I don't think this will be
controversial at all-- dancing.
Dancing is spontaneous
and seems to be
primitive for human beings,
exceptionally for human beings.
When people dance, that involves
the exquisite control, not just
of their bodies, but of
their attention-- attention
to music or attention to the
person they're dancing with.
So it's a very
intelligent activity.
Obviously, it's
spatiotemporally,
rhythmically organized.
I assume dancing serves
functions, social functions.
People dance to meet people.
People dance to celebrate.
People dance to mourn.
People dance to
express their feelings.
Those are functions in my book.
I like to illustrate
this idea that dancing
has a function by recalling
the character of Tony
Manero in the 1979 movie
"Saturday Night Fever."
Any of you old enough to
remember "Saturday Night
Fever"?
Well, darn it, if you haven't
seen it, see it tonight.
It's a good movie.
And it will take you back to
the glorious days of disco,
when I grew up.
But it's about a character.
It's played by John Travolta
named Tony Manero, who
lives in Brooklyn.
And to make a fairly
long story short,
he's got a pretty grim life.
His father is abusive.
His mother is under his thumb.
He has a job, which
he doesn't do well.
He's a clerk in
a hardware store.
And his boss, who's
kind of a good guy,
nevertheless is constantly
getting on this case.
His life is full of
drudgery and displeasure,
until Saturday
night comes, when he
puts on this duds-- his
beautiful, fancy, three-piece,
white, bell-bottom suit and
goes dancing at the disco.
And boy, does he dance.
He dances better
than all the others.
His friends go out and
all want different things.
Some of his friends are
going out to score girls.
actually going out to fight,
because they're
sort of gangsters.
He's dancing.
But why does he dance?
He dances, I think, in
order to manifest himself,
in order to actualize himself,
in order to find himself,
and in order to present
himself to the world
as a thing of value,
which is sexy, and strong,
and healthy, and young,
and not caught up
in this rather grim and
unpleasant life situation
that he has.
So for him, I would
submit-- and I'm just
choosing this as an
example, you don't
have to look far to
find other examples-- it
shows the kind of
psychological functions
that dancing can have.
As for the other two, dancing is
obviously a source of pleasure.
And I think, when people dance,
they don't decide what to do.
They can decide what to do.
But as a general
rule, dancing happens.
People get caught
up in their dances.
They get into the flow.
The situation dances for them.
But John Travolta is a sort
of bad example of that,
because they dance all
these very fixed move
steps, like the Hustle and
all these kinds of things
that they do in the
discotheques of the late '70s.
But the point stands, dancing
is an organized activity.
And now, now we come to art.
I chose dancing, because
dancing has a relationship
to choreography.
Choreography is the
art of dancing--
to give it a quick summation.
And my question to you
is, how does choreography
fit in relation to
organized activity?
Is choreography an
And you might say, well, yeah,
choreographers make dances,
and dancing is an
organized activity.
But not so fast.
If I'm right that dancing is an
organized activity, that it's
something that we get caught
up in and that organizes us,
and that serves these
kinds of embedded functions
in our lives, and
that we don't author,
then you can't make dancing.
It's not the kind of
thing you can make.
Well, you might say,
the choreographer
doesn't make dancing but the
choreographer stages dancing.
And there, I want to
say, yes, exactly.
So what does that mean?
What does it mean
to stage a dance?
Well, it means to put
a dance on the stage,
or put dancing on the stage,
or put the fact that people
are dancers on the stage, or put
the fact that we are organized
by dancing itself
on display, or put
the fact that
dancing matters to us
in the center of our attention.
In other words,
the choreographer
is not doing more dancing.
The choreographer is, in a
way, investigating the place
that dancing has in
our lives already.
The choreographer is
exhibiting that we
are dancers to ourselves.
Now, two points about that, one
is if organized activities have
this link to biology, and
if dancing is an organized
activity, and if choreography
is exhibiting or investigating
dancing in something like
the way I'm suggesting,
then we begin to see a way of
thinking about how choreography
is meshing with biology,
meshing with the investigation
of ourselves thought
of biologically,
or thought of naturally.
It's grappling with
our nature, just as
through a thin slice of it,
the dancing slice of it.
Secondly, I said
before that we're lost
in these nests of organization.
My thought is that by
choreography putting dancing
in our lives on display
in the ways that it does,
choreography is, if you like,
enabling us to get found,
if that's correct English.
It is orienting us or disclosing
to ourselves this fact
about ourselves
and, thus, helping
us be what we are, but, if you
like, without feeling lost.
Wittgenstein once said
that philosophical problems
have the form, I don't
know my way about.
So dancing in a way gives us
a perspicuous representation
of where we are.
Heidegger your once said that
philosophical problems are
bringing what's
concealed into the open.
And I'm suggesting that
choreography brings something
concealed about us
that we are organized
by dancing into the open.
So the work of choreography
is both philosophical
and also relevant to biology.
It makes a contribution
in that sense
to some kind of an
account of ourselves
biologically understood.
And this goes back
to the thought
I shared with you
at the beginning
that maybe far from it's
been the case that scientists
and neuroscientists and
evolutionary psychologists
are going to explain
art, maybe art
is going to help us frame
a more adequate conception
of our nature.
And this is, I think, an
example of the kind of way
in which it could happen.
Now again, from what I just
said, I hope it's clear,
I've chosen choreography
as, if you like,
a random art practice.
And so what I want to say
about the relationship
between choreography
and dancing,
I want to say that something
like that very same relation
holds between all the parts and
the different activities that
organize us.
Now, I have two more ideas
I want to share with you
before I conclude.
One way to summarize what I just
said is that there's dancing
and there's
choreography, where we
can think of dancing
as a first order
organized activity and
choreography as, if you like,
a second order representation
of dancing in our lives,
a kind of meta-dancing.
I called it an investigation.
I think it's very
important to realize
that, although what I said just
now, that summation is kind
of notionally accurate,
it doesn't do justice
to the reality, because
in reality, what happens
is practices, such
as choreography,
influence the way people dance.
They loop back down and change
the first order expression
of dancing.
And they do so in ways
that iterate recursively
through history, so that
in fact for us, embedded
as we are in
history and culture,
there's no such thing as dancing
immune to the model of what
dancing is, which
choreography provides to us,
whether it's Michael
Jackson or whoever, Mick
Jagger, or your mother in
the kitchen, who taught me
how to do the twist.
Whatever the source
is, our first order
lived experience with dancing
is already shaped and influenced
by second order artistic
grapplings with the place
of dancing in our lives, or
I might say with second order
philosophical grapplings
with the place
of dancing in our lives.
That means that
even kids dancing
at the discotheque, whoever
they may be, are in an art space
even if they don't
have those intentions
and if they're not
participating in an art world.
And by the way, this
looping phenomenon
is very, very widespread.
And my book discusses this in
a lot of different examples.
An important example-- I'm
just going to mention it,
because I don't
want to tire you out
with new ideas-- but
an interesting example
is writing and language.
Speech is one thing.
Writing is another.
But we, I mean us, live
in a scriptorial culture.
And our conception
of language, indeed
our conception of our own
experience as talkers,
is permeated through and through
by the picture of what language
is that writing provides us.
So writing is second order.
Speech is first order.
But in fact, it loops
back down and transforms,
so it's a much more complex
two-directional thing.
I think something very
similar goes on with pictures.
I'll just summarize
it in a sentence.
I think pictures have
changed the way we see.
And that's a very
interesting fact
when you consider
that we've been
making pictures of the
highest quality for at least
30,000 years.
So now, the point of
this last set of remarks
is to explain why I say
reorganizational practice,
because art doesn't just exhibit
our organization to ourselves,
it reorganizes us.
And it does so not by sort
of consciously giving us
tools for reorganizing
ourselves, it just changes us.
And this is very
interesting, because it
points to-- I don't know
if I emphasized this
well enough in the
book-- but it points
to what you might call the
emancipatory value of art.
The fact of the matter is that
all these organized activities,
they're habits that were trapped
inside-- ways of looking,
ways of moving, ways of
seeing, ways of talking,
ways of thinking,
ways of dressing.
They are ways that were
organized not voluntarily.
And art, I think, always changes
that, and thus changes us,
and in a sense liberates us.
Final thought before
I stop, I said
before that Tony Manero says,
look at me, I'm beautiful,
I'm sexy, I'm young.
Check me out.
That's his motto.
His motto is check me out.
I think that's exactly not
the work of art's motto.
The work of art doesn't
say, check me out.
The work of art says
something more like,
I dare you try to see me,
try to bring me into focus,
see me if you can.
And the interesting thing is
at the beginning you can't.
You're in that gallery
space, and the pictures all
look the same.
You need to change yourself
to bring the work of art
into focus.
So I'll conclude with the
thought that, if you like,
the essential project of
the work of art is to say,
see me if you can.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: The last
distinction you
were making between the
level of dance and the level
choreography, makes me
reminded of an observation
that sports video games
actually have more in common
with how sports is
presented on TV than what
it's like to actually
play the sport.
So this kind of looping
back phenomenon.
I'm curious if you see that
as analogous to the experience
of-- or analogous to like the
user level or the perceiver
level, versus like the
author or designer level.
That's something
that, obviously, we
think about a lot in terms
of this distinction-- users
and implementers or
creators or authors,
who are actually
creating the experience.
And thus, part of what
seems like you're getting at
is creating the norms
or the conventions
with which the user
then understands
the experience their having.
ALVA NOE: When you're--
I'm not a programmer,
and I don't really know
the issues that you face.
But one interesting thing that
I imagine the programmer faces
is designing environments that
give the user the affordances
the user needs to know what's
going on or to make sense,
to find the situation
intelligible.
So for that reason,
designers are
going to try to tap into
the habits and knowledge
and expectations that the user
brings to the task-- point
and click, for example.
And then as you're suggesting,
or maybe as we're both
suggesting in slightly
different words,
the user is transformed
by their new interface,
by their new engagement
and acquires new habits,
which affect how
they think and see
and respond outside of
the designed environment.
And that's remarkable.
I mean, that's real evolution.
And it's not foreseeable.
I mean, there's the silly,
stupid examples of it,
like when I punch my book trying
to get it to turn the page,
which if you're
tired enough, I'm
sure you've all done
things like that.
Or I can think of many,
many examples, where
the metaphors and models and
paradigms and a virtual space
misfire when they've taken over
into a non-virtual environment
and yet they'll do so.
One of the interesting-- if I
can just free associate for one
moment, it's interesting to
think about this in relation
to language.
One of the big questions
that people have always
asked about language--
not always asked,
but I'm thinking of sort of
people in the post Chomskian
world of linguistics
have asked--
how is it that we can learn
language as readily as we can,
given our complexities and
given how little time we
have to learn it and given how
poor the linguistic samples are
on the basis of which
we do learn it--
baby talk and inaccurate speech
as people slur their words when
they're talking.
And yet kids get it,
and they get it fast.
Well, there's an interesting
way of turning that idea around
on its head.
This is not an idea
original to me.
There's an interesting way
of turning that idea around
on its head, which is
that language, in a way,
is a user friendly system.
It's been designed through
thousands of years precisely
to be learnable by
creatures like us.
So it's not that
we are so smart.
It's that the design
process iterated
over long periods of time has
turned out to be so sufficient.
And I think something actually
similar-- in the book,
I hypothesize that something
similar goes on with pictures.
And pictures are old
world technology,
30,000-year-old technology.
But we find pictures
effortless to interpret.
Actually, that's not quite true.
We find them effortless
to interpret,
when they come with a caption.
You give a picture out of a
context, and all of a sudden,
all bets are off.
But with the caption
in the right context,
we find pictures very,
very straightforward.
So one question is,
is that-- and I just
leave this, give this to
you as a question-- is
that because they tap into
the way we naturally see?
Or is it that they've
taught how to see
in the way in which a
virtual environment can teach
a gamer or a user how to act?
AUDIENCE: The sort
of reorganization
that you describe as
occurring through art
is something that reminds
me of what happens
with education,
with psychotherapy,
with other sorts of situations
where you achieve an insight
and then you have this
nonlinear transition
in your understanding of things.
Do you see those as part
of the same category?
And if so, why did
you pick art as sort
of the prototypical
example of it.
ALVA NOE: The
discovery in the book
is that there's a
phenomenon called
reorganizational practice.
And art is one and
so is philosophy.
And by the way, that's not an
orthodox view in philosophy.
I mean, there are
people in philosophy
that would agree with me.
But many philosophers
think of themselves
as seeking knowledge or
results or making proofs
about the nature of mind
and matter and causation.
The idea that philosophy is
not about discovering truths
but is about reorganizing
us is a debatable view.
The argument of the book is
that art and philosophy matter
to us, because they are
reorganizational practices.
If the value of philosophy
depended on the truths
that philosophers had
established and come
to agree upon, philosophy
would be in trouble.
But it's not a
problem for philosophy
that no philosopher agrees
with another philosopher.
Similarly, it's
no problem for art
that art doesn't converge
on a single artistic idea.
So I think that
the idea that art
is a reorganizational
practice and that philosophy
are reorganizational
practices help
us answer the kinds of questions
I asked at the beginning.
What is art?
What is philosophy?
Why do they matter to us?
What do they teach
us about ourselves?
Now, you're asking a very
interesting question.
Are there other
reorganizational practices?
Is psychotherapy, for
example psychoanalysis,
a reorganization practice?
This terminology of
organization reorganization
is used in a number
of other fields,
for example, in the
body work field.
People like Feldenkrais
practitioners
talk about reorganizing
the body's habits
to deal with organic
problems that the body faces.
And I'm open to the
possibility that there
are other species of the genus
than just art and philosophy.
So my answer to you,
if that's the question,
is I didn't mean to suggest
that I'd given evidence
that only art and philosophy
are reorganizational practices.
But now there's a
further question,
which you might be asking.
What's the principle of
differentiation between them?
I thought about
that for a long time
in a slightly different setting.
Most of the features that
I think define works of art
are also characteristics
of jokes.
Jokes are sort of
cognitively rich.
They involve certain
kinds of shifts.
They exhibit many of the
hallmarks of works of art.
I don't know if that's
a problem for me.
Maybe joke-telling is a
species of art-making.
But I would-- oh,
there's another way.
Actually, here's another
point that's related.
Sorry if my answer is
going on much too long.
But another point
which is relevant
is playing the flute
is an art form.
Dancing hip hop is an art form.
Potting is an art form.
Making video installations
is an art form.
Building buildings
Those are all totally
different kinds of things.
So maybe the class of things
that participate-- and I
want to say that philosophy
belongs on that list-- what
makes them each
art forms, I think,
is the way in which
they're performing
reorganizational work in
different neighborhoods
of our being.
And-- and maybe this
is getting closer
to something that might have
been in the back of your mind--
and they're doing so
for that reason alone.
The artist isn't trying to get
a rocket ship to go to the moon
or to debug a program.
The artist, if I'm
right, is trying
to give us
enlightenment, is trying
to help us understand
ourselves, and in that sense,
open up the possibility
of changing ourselves.
Maybe that's a very
good explanation
of what psychoanalysis
is doing too.
That's a good question.
It's an open question to me.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
I thank you for your attention.